Imagine growing stunning flowers without
soil. Sounds crazy. Welcome to
hydroponic flower farming. Hydroponics
is the magic trick to growing gorgeous
flowers like roses, maragolds, and
patunias right in your home or balcony.
No dirt, no mess. Here's how you can
start. First, choose your system.
Kratki, deep water culture, or tower
systems. They're perfect for small
spaces and super easy to set up. Next,
pick your flowers. Easy grow options
like maragolds and patunias are a great
start. They thrive in hydroponic systems
and look stunning. Don't forget the
essentials: light, nutrients, and water.
Your flowers need the right balance to
flourish. And here are some quick tips.
Keep an eye on water levels. Check pH
regularly, and ensure good air flow.
Avoid common pitfalls like overwatering
or ignoring pH levels. Trust me, a
little attention goes a long way. So,
what are you waiting for? Join the
hydroponic flower revolution. Like and
share if you found this helpful. Hash
hydroponics. Hash flower farming.